here's another big question for you that
doesn't have a simple answer i would
imagine but one of the things that
impressed me most
about what you do in this movie is
alyssa goes on a pretty significant arc
but she's a supporting character with
limited screen time so what were kind of
the pillars of that journey that were
absolute musts
in order to make that journey that she
goes on
work in the end because it just it blew
my mind
how all of that worked so well and hit
me so
hard in the end but then if i add up you
know the amount of screen time everybody
has
you had less to work with but you
accomplished that much
thank you i'm so glad that that's how
you received it
like that is the greatest compliment
thank you so much
um you know i think it's how you
described it there are very specific
moments
and if you don't land those moments then
you have not done
this girl justice i think when it comes
to
number one you have to cultivate
that chemistry with emma that was
important to me
because you don't see the girls together
a lot right
so i had a short amount of time to to
try and make the audience believe that
like
this is the girl i want to be with right
and that's
that has to do with just natural
chemistry and if it wasn't there
um shot in the foot but thankfully
how can you not look at joe ellen
hillman and be like
totally taken by her she's incredible um
and then again you know there's a coming
out moment there's the
which is it's the coming out moment
like you you have to land that and it's
there's several layers on it she's a
girl of color coming out to a black mama
and that's tough so
if if i didn't have the life experience
i have i wouldn't have been able to
endow that with
half of what it holds um
you know i don't know that i have a good
answer for your question and it's such a
good question
but i think ultimately
i don't know that someone could have
played this role on screen without
having these very specific experiences
you know or understanding that life
experience i do
applaud ryan for making the choice to
hire
girls women young women who identify
somewhere on the rainbow spectrum
because if you don't walk that walk you
cannot talk the talk
in this case this particular case um
and you know being a woman of color
specifically it's a complicated order
living in 2020 so
having the material even though it's
not a huge uh
amount of material there was enough
space to go through that
to go through the emotions of that and
if she had had less material than what
is actually there i don't know if we
would have been successful
you